traitement du courrier triple à bobby
on commence à parler normal on commence
parlant normalement et il m'a dit que je
J'ai dû m'améliorer un peu et maintenant
ne pouvait pas aider et que j'ai fait le
demander pourquoi et il m'a dit que je
je dois y aller je dois venir à quoi
viser à aider l'équipe à gagner
Eh bien, nous pouvons et vous ne pouvez pas
continuer après le jeu que je peux déjà
dire parce qu'ils n'ont pas encore vu
tu ne m'as pas vu jouer et quand je
voir agir peut-être que vous verrez un
centimètre lit et les choses seront différentes
bien ce que j'essaie je vais essayer
contrôler ce que je peux contrôler
sait sortir du terrain et donner le meilleur de
ma
en un temps ce que je fais parle
parlera de lui-même
Eh bien, je pense la même chose que je ressens
tu le sens aussi
et signifie tout à fait savoir signifie
assez et ce qu'il m'a dit pour aujourd'hui, je
Je pense qu'il fait toujours mon travail et
continue de jouer comme je joue avec
allez-y tout ne va pas bien
Je pense qu'il a progressé dans tout ce que vous savez
Je n'ai pas la majorité, je pense un peu plus
l'a défendue sait pourquoi surtout
nous lisons nous lisons
donné beaucoup de concentration et beaucoup d'efforts dans le
la défense et je le fais toujours tu sais
pourquoi pas le jeu non seulement fouetté
mais vous devez aussi défendre votre bouche et
tu sais parfois ton truc c'est la défense
eh bien je pense que le petit parce que
J'ai appris en personne ne lui a appris
une fois arrêter de faire une mauvaise balle
parce qu'une fois il a frappé un piconazo et
la balle a rebondi sur la batte et à moitié sur le nez
et a cessé de passer des appels
travailler dur travailler dur
Et j'ai toujours confiance dans le dieu qui a donné le
qui supprime ce que vous avez mis et donné supprime ce que cela
le site met l'équipement
[Musique]